[Laughter]
sorry don't mind me I'm just busy making
myself at home after all you know what
was Northern as a light right well
actually allow me to be serious for a
minute and I'll tell you was northerners
alike compared to you southerners from
income to life expectancy child poverty
through to job prospects the North fairs
far worse in the South since austerity
began public spending in the North has
fallen by six point three billion pounds
while spending in the South has actually
risen by 3.2 billion this divide must be
taken seriously it is one of the reasons
the brexit vote happened and whoever our
new prime minister is he must create a
new cabinet seat for the northern
powerhouse minister and as far as more
devolution goes we'd happily get on our
bike and manage our own affairs life
exists beyond the Watford gap Nick and
if we truly want to make our country the
best it can be post brexit we must give
them off what it deserves
[Music]
well Michelle luckily you took those
chips and gravy away otherwise I
wouldn't have been able to speak to you
my feelings well listen I agree with you
but I actually actually really
frustrated because this is a subject
that every successive government and
almost every politician or somebody in
their cabinet that constantly seems to
promise to redress the balance in
north-south divide George Osborne was
the last one that day nothing seems to
ever-blooming happen and it's just so
frustrating for me I mean he says it's
it's so palpable that we have a weighted
country and let me just put it spread
out in abstract terms rather than facts
and figures but in most countries let's
take the u.s. their political capital is
separate from their media capital which
is separate from their financial capital
so clearly la New York and DC we've got
all three in one
city and then we moan about congestion
pollution wait I'm gonna I'm gonna
suggest something drastically radical to
solve this problem once and for I'm
gonna give him a snack in our Palace of
Westminster is about the wrong part it's
in the Palace of Westminster is in
desperate need of repair right
I suggest we relocate Parliament to the
north relocate our political capsule we
don't need those politicians in London
anyway I mean they need to be closer to
their constituencies move the political
capital up North London can stay with
the rest of the economy because it's a
strong economy here but at least that
way we we shift some of the center of
gravity somewhere else I think that
needs to be done thank you I agree
imagine there we are I mean I completely
agree with you Michelle I would and one
thing I don't think goes far enough the
caveat is I don't necessarily want to
set up an us-versus-them divide you know
you look at some of the most deprived
constituencies are in London 7 out of 20
I think so it's not as clear-cut
although I do agree with you more
broadly but I don't think you go far
enough I mean you all sit around
laughing when I mentioned market Marxist
economics a Marxist analysis of this I
would look at would look at the reasons
why the north and south why there is
such structural inequality between the
two and apply mechanisms to reduce that
so one of the things you might look at
us at what is one of the things you
might look at what what is that when
it's at home is something like a
regional investment bank okay so a
regional investment bank because you
know the region's know best for
themselves where things should be where
they where the investment is required in
socialism
welcome aboard comrade Michelle even
though this was this even though this
would actually tackle the inequalities
that you're talking about which I agree
with I'm I'm not I'm a fan of
responsible capitalism I wouldn't
advocate shifting to a socialist agenda
I think it would be absolutely terrible
so you don't think a regional investment
bank is a good idea now I don't think we
needs have original investment banks
though I would say that what we need to
do I agree with you by the way I think
power is too centralized geographically
in London and I think that is ridiculous
for many different reasons and by the
way if I did relocate any
they can't make you make sure that
you're traveling there on a weekly basis
just to annoy you I think that we do
need the devolution of powers we need
proper long term strategies about what
we're actually going to do and we need
proper investment in transport links
particularly east to west you're not
already told my investment it's all
right you're talking about subsidy what
you're talking about is saying there's a
pool of money
there's thought of money a
disproportionate amount of it generated
by London and this is not London
chauvinism it just happens to be the
case but that's that's how the economics
works right now and what you want is
more of that money generated by London
to be parked somewhere else well okay
that's fine if you could show exactly
what you're saying and that that's
exactly what you're saying because what
you've just described Rachel is what
used to be called a command economy you
have globally misconstrued what you say
I listened to what you said and what you
basically is saying people who believe
this stuff they want somebody in
Whitehall to be sitting saying okay
we've got this amount of tax money let's
put more of it in Manchester let's put
more of it that's fine if that's what if
that's a kind of society you want to
live in but the problem is the size
everything like that
can I just freeze what I wanted to say I
just want to say can I just say one
thing
Michele I think there is an imbalance
but my view is I think you've got the
wrong one you're talking about a fiscal
imbalance and you can't nobody's been
able to fix that the thing that is
absolutely true when you see this in the
United States you see it in Canada you
see it in parts of Europe the thing that
marks successful cities and regions is
their ability to bring people from
elsewhere what London hers was New York
has what Los Angeles has its huge
numbers of immigrant who work hard who
make money who build those economies
where there is no let me finish the last
sentence there is not it is not an
accident but London is our richest
region lots of immigrants northeast
poorest zilch
well I wonder we go put Michelle dubas
introduction through the facts
checker sneering about me I'd need to
tell you my mother was born in
Lancashire and moved to Leicester at the
age of four so I have northern roots as
you see it when I suggest that the
northern powerhouse Minister talked
about how you don't love to get on your
bikes and have you the idea I think
bought in by your new boyfriend John
Prescott of regional assemblies was
absolutely rejected by the electorate
they had no interest regional Simmons
stank the house out I go on you talk
about 3.2 billion more pounds being
spent in the south can I tell you what
we're spending 56 billion pounds on a
bloody stupid railway line that nobody
wouldn't London once they don't want to
in Camden they don't you're a Chester
they don't want it in Houston they don't
want in Buckinghamshire so that we can
connect up to Birmingham and they're not
to Sheffield and then across and my
final point please I have been quite
they are phenomenal and that and every
government upon I think I pay my tax to
Bradford I like my license one car
engines up north please can we send the
policies that they need to be down here
because the Department of Culture Media
sporty Trevor I must reiterate my point
I am being deadly serious that you must
have the northern powerhouse minister in
the camera so that the north is properly
represented in a place where decisions
have been truly made